so at the risk of sounding nostalgic
growing up in the 80s gave me a sense of
certainty the UK and the US special
relationship the european community and
nato all served as counterweights to the
Soviet domination of Eastern Europe we
knew where the threats were and we
worked collaboratively to protect
ourselves fast-forward to the present
day and to chemical attacks from British
soil with two fatalities and things have
certainly heated up again our response
to these aggressions have been
inadequate and has shown our
vulnerability and isolation as Hillary
Clinton declared this week it's time to
stand up to Russia and Vladimir Putin
but president Trump has shown we cannot
depend on the transatlantic relationship
so we in Britain must take the lead
ourselves if we are dead set on the path
of brexit then we need to ensure that
our part of our deal with the EU
includes assurances from them for
collective action if we just keep calm
and carry on and hope for the best
then we are playing Russian roulette
with our national security I totally
agree on with most of that I think that
we need to acknowledge that the Russians
it was in the Russians interest they're
very open about the fact that they
wanted the UK to leave to brexit they
wanted to see the if possible the
collapse of the EU because of course in
terms of military power it out punches
Russia my long way and also Putin said
that the collapse of the Soviet Union
was the greatest catastrophe in world
history yeah so he wants to see the
collapse of a rival Empire yeah on
security there they're ours going to be
no softening of the EU security policy
we hope I mean in the current
negotiation security is absolutely a red
line a blood red line in the negotiation
because of the Russian threat but just
lastly before yield we have to also
acknowledge that the Russians are just
laughing us whatever we do to retaliate
to
strong you are collectively nationally
despite the expulsion of hundreds of
diplomats I think it means nothing it's
nothing and it's just that you know we
have Keystone Cops who came to Salisbury
let's just have a clip of that pair who
we think we know poisoned descript pals
and the old dawn Burgess what were you
doing there our friends had been
suggesting for a long time that we visit
this wonderful town
Salisbury a wonderful town yes there's
the famous Salsbury Cathedral famous not
only in Europe but in the whole world
it's famous for its 123 meter spire is
famous for its clock I mean it is
hilarious but it's also really sad right
that they are trailing us so bad before
I bring you in to sitting then I will
bring you in can I just go through the
list of Russian aggression this is
frightening so if we bring this up in
November 2006 former Russian spy
Alexander Litvinenko was murdered in
Britain in March 2014 Russia invaded and
annexed the region of Crimea in Ukraine
Malaysia Airlines flight 17 was shot
down on July 2014
killing 298 people an investigation in
the US has announced indictments against
12 Russians all members of the Russian
intelligence service for interference in
the 2016 US election in March sergey
skripnikov re and last week a coalition
of Western nations accused Russian
military intelligence of carrying out a
worldwide campaign of malicious cyber
attacks Carol you know I think the most
important that we have to get to grips
with now is cyber warfare so Tony
Brennan who was a Russian ambassador
sorry the prision bastard of Russia
between 2004 2008 he warned us what he
said the world is in danger of falling
into a world war situation because of
this cyber warfare which we know now can
[ __ ] a country here weaker and more
devastatingly than any conventional war
and the only more devastating thing
would be a nuclear when we know that's
never going to happen so it has to be it
has to be that we also have to get to
grips with you know Russia was
weaponizing social media we've seen that
happening a lot and we've all seen the
bosses of social media doing absolutely
zero about it I was on a show this week
with a guy called Bill Browder who was
who was who was a reputed to be Putin's
greatest enemies trying to get him has
has issued 12 arrest warrants to try and
get him russian corrupt officials took
230 million quid out of a hedge fund
that he had and I think he said he said
that that Putin would almost certainly
have ordered the hit on the scribbles
through the the giu the military
intelligence arm he would also have
order the hit on little checker so him
without his approval yeah and well no he
said personally ordered now you know
this this is a guy who's using chemical
weapons in our country one of the things
brad ursin
sharp he said that one of the weapons we
have against Putin is that that he's
probably the richest man of the world he
has a fortune of hundreds of billions
and what we can do in the West he has a
lot of that money in the West what we
could do was freeze the assets take the
money but but as Bradley said we're not
doing it and we're not doing it because
there's too many snouts in the trough
all over the world so we could reduce
his power but we're not doing it and in
the meantime he could take our power
stations out he could paralyze our
utilities could paralyze the National
Health Service any time you want an
hourglass you just one question and I'll
bring an aspirin and I don't want to
make this about breaks it but don't you
think that breaks it does make us more
vulnerable in this incident its nature
it's not the EU that is the bulwark
against Russia its NATO no one's coming
out of NATO so don't worry about that
look a couple of things here and we'll
get on to the money aspect in just a
second it's all very well he leave
Hillary Clinton saying it's time to
stand up to Russia in what way let's put
some meat on the bone Rachel when you
say that everyone's laughing it I don't
what we saw
no hold on hold on I think the way that
mrs. may and security services went
about piecing together the evidence was
compelling
bear in mind those well-known brass
rubbers that we saw on television just
now they only performed on television
because Radomir Putin called for them to
show themselves Russian today then when
they show themselves journalists watch
them and say that's not that that's that
bloke who was a doctor so there they've
been unmasked because of Putin if we
laughing at anybody it's Putin's
stupidity for telling those blokes to go
on the telly and then they've been
identified it would never have happened
if you haven't told Carmen back to it
and then we must get out for it let's
just talk about the amount of money that
I think you're right this is stat we
can't stand up to the military let's go
for the cash let's go for a crash cash
grab let's grab them by the rubles and
if we look at global it's their currency
rich if you look at Global Witness 34
billion pounds of Russian money is
currently invested in the British
overseas territories and Transparency
International has identified 4.4 billion
pounds worth of UK properties bought
with suspicious wealth of which more
than 1/5 were purchased by Russian
individuals go for the cash that's
something we could do why we all do
unexplained wealth orders my checks the
Russian economy was only roughly the
same size as its knees economy you know
for such a huge country
economy is very vulnerable to sanctions
and I think we could do so much more on
that I think you know when when the
Salisbury attack happened I was one of
the people who was uncomfortable with
the rush to say that this was like yes
because I wanted to see the evidence but
you know now it's becoming more clear
how Russian intelligence works and the
fact that they actually tried to
interfere with the office for the
Prevention of chemical weapons even
being able to produce in their doing
that's the whole process and the thing
is you know we live in a world built on
a rules-based system we have had since
the Second World War
thanks to Churchill has you know I have
very patriotic feelings about and
Roosevelt a rules-based system we were
things wrong have worked against him
Russia and that's what I was going so
well Russia is a country that is
continuing to show it has no respect for
the rules and it's very difficult when
you are bound by rules to know how to
deal with the country and some ones are
playing both
we shouldn't have to wait until he
commits attacks on our soil oh yeah
about the state of Rights in Russia